we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
working on life below zero can be very
dangerous guns here cameras you never
know what to expect you see that gonna
be tough but we're gonna get the shot
every scenario we got to prepare for
this but we're still smiling or having
fun
still making like below zero yes
bring it on so 20 19 I did her odd death
excited to be back this year we're just
trying to keep up keep up with our boy
Jesse Holmes I'm back to the Iditarod
for my second run last year was my
rookie run it was an incredible
experience for me as a dog racer I feel
like after last year this is what I'm
cut out for in my mushroom career it
really changed my life honestly it's
we've worked really hard for years for
it today is the official start of the
race you got to have all your things
together because once you leave here
it's a thousand miles and now
we're setting off for 1,000 mile ride
our goal is to just get out in front of
most of the pack without having to pass
many or any mushers film Jessie stories
see how the race involves for him day to
day should be pretty amazing
just get stuck nacho how you doing are
you stuck maybe if you come up here
you'll you'll be on some firm enough
ground to pull me out started off well
we got some great shots with Jesse and
then everything just went to hell I hit
this huge pocket of overflow sunk my tow
sled my machine stopped moving and I was
just threw up my hands like but next
enough so the trail basically just
disintegrated around us you're in this
slush pond and the snow machines lose
traction sleds get stuck and we just
ground to a halt
[Music]
just basically just keep full-throttle
keep the faith and hopefully you can
keep up the momentum and make it through
the ice
thirty miles of horrendous overflow it
sounds like we're gonna have a really
slow-moving trail you know it's always a
good day when you don't actually think
you're gonna die so it definitely could
have been worse but at least it wasn't
open water
nacho and I have just arrived at the
blow hole which notoriously last year
kicked our asses and I'm gonna go inside
there and we're gonna film Jessie going
bye I've been dreaming of this shot of
Jessie coming through and having a
camera set up in this window
he's coming pretty quick right now on
the trail so we're gonna get in there
the other tricky part is we don't have
any communication with Jessie and so he
keeps turning off his headlamp to kind
of just enjoy the ride we never really
know when he's coming or not
sometimes we set up and he just goes by
in the dark and we can barely see him
don't get a shot at all so this could be
worth nothing in the end
eighteen men
you finally got some sleep last night
we've been gone 40 hours 30 hours
something like that without sleep
getting up early I'm doing all that we
had to do to cover Jesse's race we
weren't sure whether we were going to be
able to do it but it worked out great
and we're feeling really proud that
we've kind of pulled this off and we've
made a lot of friends along the way it's
incredible to see how people come out
for this race all the people in the
villages who just come out to cheer on
the mushers and see the dogs all the
kids that come out and the enthusiasm
that they showed to welcome people to
their home just to have that word fired
up we're excited a long trip we were 12
days out on the trail day and night
really very little sleep kind of living
the life of an Iditarod musher so we
made it to no over a thousand miles on
the trail safe and sound in one piece
feels pretty amazing to be here
[Music]
really feel privileged to do this trip
of a lifetime really to be able to come
out here and and travel the trail
experience it that was really special to
be a part of that
[Music]